in the allotted time it took to build a
prop and actually shoot something
practically where you actually get
everything in camera can you actually
get to that same bar of quality using
nothing but digital tools i built the
prop i want to be killed yeah
let's kill adam savage let's do it
so you're directing a movie and you
gotta decide do you do this effect for
real and capture it in camera or do you
do it later on in post-production using
computers and visual effects which one
looks better which one saves you the
most money which one's gonna make you
the best movie this question has been
discussed millions of times on the
internet and today we're gonna answer it
or at least we're going to explore it
you know it's there's no simple answer
to this question however i do find this
really compelling to just figure out in
the allotted time it took to build a
prop and actually shoot something
practically where you actually get
everything in camera can you actually
get to that same bar of quality using
nothing but digital tools and of course
we are going to be testing this concept
with none other than adam savage adam
invited us up to san francisco to check
out this prop that he's working on based
on the scene from this movie chinatown
where jack nicholson gets his nose cut
open you know what happens to nosy
fellas
huh they lose their noses
dude it looks really good what makes
that work is that like you see a tip of
the knife disappear inside of his nose
and then go laterally out you can't do
that because there's nose in the way and
you see his nose itself like could
stretch the nostril yeah he's actually
acting as if his nose was sliced open
because it's like when you're splattered
with blood it's hard it's a very
visceral feeling i imagine now we don't
know exactly how this effect was done
but adam has studied the scene frame by
frame in order to reverse engineer not
just the prop but the blood splatter
even timed every moment of the build
which of course you can watch right now
on the tested youtube channel we're
gonna take that amount of time and give
that same amount of time to a visual
effects artist in this case fenner to
see what they can do with the exact same
amount of time and resources now if the
shot is as good or better that has some
interesting implications we'll discuss
why if it's worse same thing at the end
of the day it's all a learning
experience for us to judge the nuances
and complexities around this topic and
what one has to think about if you are a
director or producer you're trying to
decide between actual practical effects
or digital effects
all right guys you are in luck it turns
out that the original prop knife made
for chinatown by prop master logan
frazee fraser don't know what the actual
pronunciation went on auction a few
years back and this is a picture of the
actual knife okay from chinatown now
there's a few things i learned about
this that are really cool one is is that
it's a fake knockoff of an italian
stiletto and i know this because i can
see from this just as stainless steel
and the italian one it would actually
have the name here and it'll also be on
the blade this knock off was what every
hollywood prop master used for
switchblades it's in terminator it's
everywhere okay but i had a really
impossible time finding a cheap knockoff
that was 30 years old because they've
all fallen apart oh so i ended up buying
a really nice italian stiletto
um which is a much better guard on it
and this is my here is my chinatown
knife when i took the blu-ray that i had
and freeze framed it there is one frame
in which you can see
the tip bent
just just the one thing that's just a
shadow of the tip back so i was thinking
about the tip and i was thinking about
doing a mechanical pivot like some sort
of direct mechanical pivot to get it out
of the way and then i realized i was
thinking too
elaborately which is one of my pensions
uh and so instead
i simply used a spring you'll see if you
go ahead and
flick that it does not it's a very very
gentle so i i knew i was on to the right
track and then i also you know this is
just a straight tom savini blood rig
right fill this with fake blood squeeze
it blood comes out here so you took two
different knives chopped them up ground
them down attached all this stuff to it
tested it how much time did that take
you about two and a half hours two and a
half hours that's not a lot of time
i consider that up till that successful
camera test is all time spent getting us
to work including this shot right so
whatever time we spend getting this to
to go is part of my build time that
makes sense because you can execute a
practical thing like this you have to
practice and rehearse and nail it all
right let's load the knife up with some
blood i think you're also going to be
thrilled by the blood so this blood was
given to me by the breakaway effects
crew on alien covenant
ridley wanted so much blood for this
movie
that they had to just make their own and
they made like 3 000 gallons of oh wow
so as soon as they told me that i was
like can i can i have some
like what goes into like fake blood so
it is a little bit of corn syrup a
little bit of water you always want to
add some corn starch for a little
opacity and then it's never just red you
always add a little bit of blue and a
little bit of green and to darken it and
give it a little more body there's much
more green in humans than anyone
realizes
[Laughter]
i was thinking that you'd be slicing my
nose oh really well i built a prop i
want to be killed yeah
yeah let's kill adam savage let's do it
do you want rock paper scissors to see
who gets to do it you can do it
[Laughter]
you don't want the pressure
i don't want to be responsible for
hurting you
i'm not worried about that it's actually
just about getting the timing the way i
worked it out was
it's easy to think of it as swipe and
squeeze
but it's more like probably it's swipe
it is it's like think about the
squeezing first and then and then move
just before you do it and so i think you
should practice if you're going to do it
you should practice a couple times make
sure we feel good about it
all right you have some nosy guys
they lose the noses
i didn't do it it's hard enough i
thought this was going to be easy this
is actually a lot more difficult it's
because you need to do the blood right
you need the timing right you can't hurt
your actor you need to do a slice just
right you need to hide the bulb yeah you
need to clear the frame they need to
react like
it's a whole thing a lot there's like
this you're getting this is exactly what
practical effects work is always like
let me also tell you this about being a
practical effects guy on set is that you
don't experience in cg is that when i'm
doing my job
everybody is staring at me oh this hurts
the gaffers are like that shit's not
gonna work they will tell you that
you're an idiot right as you're doing
the effect while the director is yelling
at you the grips are everyone's waiting
for you to fail everyone's you know we
cost 20 10 grand a minute right
you do your job under the most egregious
duress when you are a practical effects
person
so please think about that while you're
doing your visual effects maybe imagine
having 10 people behind you staring at
your screen thinking about every mouse
click you're making so now we have
officially restarted working on the
practical bit here which means we're on
the clock so all this time right now is
counting towards oh yeah
let's see nicholson actually so let's
just stand where you're going to slice
this way yep nicholson camera's here so
slicing's ah oh and moves like that
so it's like this is like yeah yeah
yep
oh by the way nico i totally forgot to
tell you this is what i'm wearing to the
met gala tonight it is imperative you
don't get any blood on me at all or else
you ruin everything sorry just bring
this on yet last minute let's go
actually real talk though i am a little
nervous and i have a little bit of
adrenaline going but it's just because i
really want to get it right is that okay
oh yeah it's fine i'm good i'll tell you
if i'm kind of yeah that's great all
right here we go
i'm speeding speeding and speeding niko
let me see the knife in place just so we
make sure that we're not gonna have it
wait
i'm seeing i'm seeing tube i'm seeing
two of when you bring it up oh okay okay
yeah you really got it
we're on the clock niko
rolling
huh what are you saying about visual
effects that practical effects are
better
you don't think visual effects can cut
it
i'll show you cutting it
wow
was that great it looked
i got it on claude it's practical record
all the time it takes me to get cleaned
up
wait wait brent did you get any on your
shirt that you're wearing to the met
gala oh my god i didn't
it makes a perfect splatter yeah i think
we got the shot oh all right and that
timer total add time to adam savage's
build time
1553. okay now it is time to shoot the
vfx plate so here we have the practical
knife that i haven't built and here we
have the knife we're going to use for
vfx luckily enough adam needed the tip
from the second knife so we have a
perfect vfx knife why is this a perfect
vfx knife niko well if you've seen other
videos on our channel where we talk
about swords and knives often we talk
about half blades because in movies
these days when they're stabbing people
and cutting them up
they just cg in the tip of the sword but
they keep the hat the other half of the
sword or blade so when you poke somebody
with it you're not like it's not just
like floating around on their chest
right right so this is actually perfect
so one thing we're going to do for the
visual effects version of this shot
we're going to film it the same way it's
going to be handheld and then do the
same motion
slice
i think we got what we need for vfx yes
oh so we're done that's a wrap
okay so we're gonna use some really cool
computers the software see you later
we'll make it look good later all right
we've recorded our shots now we're going
to go back and spend the same amount of
time with a visual effects artist to see
if they can make the shot look as good
as the practical one i love this this is
so much fun i don't care who wins i love
the ex don't get me wrong i know i win
but
i love you
about that
i love the exercise i would love to hear
uh their ideas about practical versus
digital effects we could play with in
the future because this
is already some of the most fun i've had
in a while and i can't wait to see how
it turns out i mean i know i win but
i
really still can't wait to see how i
mean we'll see if you guys got any ideas
for where like it might help out us
i want to see those comments
all right adam we're going to get back
to la we're working the shot and we'll
show you the results are you calculating
flight time to la in your time
we'll get back to you
all right we're back from san francisco
it was an amazing trip oh boy like
pretty cool
but this isn't about how cool our trip
was it's about getting the shot right so
we have the shot that we did practically
with adam and it looks really good
oh that looks awesome it looks pretty
cool doesn't it it looks super cool as
good as the actual shop yeah
yeah so the thing that we didn't
anticipate is how much blood ended up on
my face which is a great like sells it
yeah it feels like you get all the nice
like real timing here where it's like
you know something happens your body
instinctively reacts and then like your
brain figures out what happens then you
get like a second layer of reaction but
here's the problem fenner the knife tip
wobbles when i stick it in adam's nose
so it's not any good we can't use it
can't do any visual effects in this shot
but we did it a second time so you guys
had to reset refilm everything i think
that adds to my timer a little bit it
does it all counts so here's the second
take
yeah the knife definitely sells a lot
better in this take not quite as extreme
on the blood slice but in a way like
it's more realistic on adam's face but
you just don't get the made major blood
splatter on ren you get a little bit
i kind of do like the blood splatter
pattern on adam's face in this shot more
but i think the overall blood from the
first shot is still a better shot so
that's something we can maybe do is
actually like try to fix that first
practical shot but that's not why we're
here right now we have a clean plate
version of this where there wasn't any
knife tip or blood or any of that so
let's take a look at that shot because
that's what you're actually going to be
working with fenner
it's a little delayed in the reaction
hey the performance from all of us isn't
as good as when we did it practically
that's just one of the benefits of
shooting practically with stuff like
that it's you have actual the shock of
getting blood on your face you feel that
tug of the actual like collapsing knife
tip but fender's gonna have a hard time
matching this in terms of its quality i
have a feeling so the easy parts are
going to be just finding the elements
we've got some great action vfx blood
elements we can use for this the hard
parts are going to be matching them to
what we're actually seeing in our
practical shot here obviously perfect
motion blur the tracking is perfect
because it's just actually there on
adam's face a big thing is going to be
those reflections in the blood that'll
be tricky to emulate for sure it's going
to be interesting i think the the
biggest thing that i'm noticing is the
performance difference i think it'll be
doable but it's definitely going to be a
challenge finner adam told us it took
him about 2 hours and 31 minutes to
build this prop and that is how long you
have to get as close as you can to the
final practical shot if you can't get
there let's keep going and see how long
it does take you to actually get there
most importantly i want to see given the
same amount of time where does visual
effects end up compared to practical
effects we'll try it
[Music]
one hour down exactly
things are going well
starting to make some good progress here
we've got the blood tracked on adam's
face in my opinion one of the most
powerful tools that the foundry has
added to nuke in recent years smart
vectors before something like smart
vectors you'd be you know trying to 2d
track this
maybe grid warping it around to try to
match the subtle little motions that
adam's face has as he's acting as if his
nose just got sliced and the incredible
thing about smart vectors is it gets all
those little minute details and it
essentially does the majority of the
intense tracking labor for us something
like this wouldn't have been feasible in
this amount of time even just a few
short years ago so i'm really really
thankful to the team at the foundry
thank you guys i think it's looking
pretty good i'm just working on those
little reflection details next up i
think i'm gonna do that knife tip which
might be a little bit tricky but we'll
see how it goes
freaking out freaking out
got it buddy
you got it you're doing great i'm a
little worried because real world stakes
like defender doesn't win this that's a
huge mark on the visual effects
community to where you know
realistically
could be the death of the visual effects
community i think corridor closes its
doors i think we start something new
maybe we become farmers i don't i don't
think we could be in better hands but
i'm sitting here kind of stressing about
it
how long have you spent on this so far
an hour 56 so far so you did almost
everything in the
dude totally worked i got a little track
of the knife
and then basically just
wrote the knife blade did a little soft
rotor for the tip and basically just
transformed it up so we get all the nice
little reflection details i would say
like as the reflections change oh you
got the blood in there too on it yeah
just that little extra to kind of parent
the little extension with the practical
blade it's moving his nose you got the
nose movement in there too
oh my god
heck yeah it's honestly it's come
together a lot quicker than i expected
but a huge part of that is just like
availability of the tools we have in
nuke and nowadays like it makes our jobs
easier for sure great work man this is
nice thank you dude yeah so i'm just
gonna spend a little bit more time on
this try to get it all buttoned up i
think i have another hour left to go but
once it's done i'll render it out and
we'll be ready to show adam
[Music]
how's it going adam very good how are
you gentlemen today we're ready we did
the work well actually i shouldn't say
we fender here did the work so defender
was our victim he had to go up against
you you know you're a master of
practical fender is a master of digital
so i'm curious to see the two combined
but first what was your final tally in
terms of time to build the knife now we
also added in the amount of time it took
to film
the effect and the total was two hours
31 minutes and 18 seconds wow okay
that's pretty fast that's pretty fast
did you actually get it done sooner or
later it would have been slightly longer
than that i think it was two hours 56
minutes
but you did have a finished version that
could have worked in about two hours
yeah oh smoking like a true producer the
rest is good enough print it
it sounds like we're pretty close it
sounds like fenders maybe a few minutes
over it's comparable we'll call it even
in the wash right here's a thought
we're going to show you with take and
you tell us if this is the practical
version
or if this is the digital version okay
all right yeah sure i'll take that
challenge all right here we go all right
knows a guy huh you know what dude those
guys around here want to guess do ya or
losing noses
that was the digital got it
[Laughter]
what gave it away adam i knew that we
left blood on wren's face both times
with my tanks there is technically some
blood splatter on my face in the shot
yeah not enough not enough
we did actually get two different takes
of the practical shot the first take was
the better take unfortunately it was
unusable when i stuck the knife into
your nose i didn't get it cleanly in
there so the blade wobbles as it goes in
if we had to do like a no digital
effects version whatsoever the second
take is one we had to go with the ideal
way of doing this is to combine both to
do your practical with visual effects so
he took that first take and he cleaned
up the wobble on the knife so it's
usable and here's our
both techniques married together version
knows a guy huh you know what dude knows
guys around here you want to guess do
you oh man that goes way up in there
it's hard to beat that blood splatter
yeah looking at these shots what
differences stand out to you i'm
impressed with the blood spatter on the
digital one it's really really lovely
nice work
if anything the digital
my reaction's a little bit tighter on it
because there's this delay with the
practical where i pause but then in the
original film nicholson also pauses
right after the blood hits as he's like
blood
and then moves i was trying to do the
same thing but i think the timing works
just a little better on the digital it's
interesting to mention that because that
was like our biggest observation too is
the performances are actually pretty
different between the two while you're
right it's tighter in the digital one in
our opinion
the practical one gets this really real
reaction you end up with the blood in
your eye it makes you jump a little bit
you can almost tell it for a moment you
forget where you are and then everything
reconnects like oh yeah i gotta hit
these beats then you go back into it
that gives it this authenticity that the
digital version doesn't quite have and
this also goes to exactly the thing that
directors with the clout of ridley scott
want to build
big fat sets that put their actors
inside a real environment because you're
always going to get something better
when there's real stuff around i think
in the real world there's not like a
clear answer of like which one's better
practical or digital it's really at the
end of the day the best version is
usually a combination of both of them at
this point with the kind of stuff that
john knowle and the team at mandalorian
is doing
practical effects are also
lowering in their cost and what it takes
to implement them so i mean i think that
what you guys ended up doing that's the
best take which is that hybrid of the
physical and the digital is exactly
what's happening in the industry the
institutional knowledge is now coming
full circle to encompass both
i love the fact that we did dueling
banjos between digital and this
hilariously simple rig i just think this
illuminates everything that we love
about special effects right because it's
not about one method being better than
the other it's about the problem solving
of getting the story onto the screen in
a way that's emotionally involving right
yeah thank you for doing this this
project with us it was really cool to
explore it from both angles and get the
results out of it and i'm glad that i
can now say that i have restrained adam
savage
you know oftentimes when you reveal the
secret of a magic trick the response is
disappointment but i feel like with
something like this it's absolutely the
opposite it's like a thrill that
something so simple has such a powerful
impact it's a clever solution that when
you see it you're like oh this is super
clever i love it as opposed to like oh
you just lied to me
[Laughter]
this is not the last time i want to do
this i totally want to figure out
another effect to play with you guys
this is
this seems to me like a rich mind to uh
to start digging in i agree 100 we'd
love to do more of these if you want to
see these videos coming out you should
subscribe to quarter crew and to test it
we'll have links to them in the
description everywhere else also leave a
comment for any practical versus digital
effects that you might want to see we
can use those as some inspiration as we
explore this further